good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight it'd be funny to a pole sometime
and ask people who live in Washington DC
have you ever met Joe Biden personally
and I bet a strikingly large percentage
would say yes Biden has been in
Washington forever how long here's some
perspective Joe Biden first ran for
president more than 30 years ago didn't
go well to put it mildly at the time
Biden was caught stealing details from
another man's biography Neil Kinnock's
biography and forced to drop out in a
humiliating scandal people who knew him
though always thought he would try again
for the presidency and of course he is
though this year seems a pretty strange
time to do it it's hard in fact to
imagine a candidate more out of step
with the moment he's running Biden is
old and pale at a time when his party
worships youth and diversity Biden spent
decades cultivating a reputation
deserved for not as a moderate at a time
when his party is moving hard to the
left as of right now though Biden is
still the frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination but it's not a comfortable
fit so what exactly is Joe Biden running
on well if you guessed ideas have
another beer you've obviously had a few
beers already if you think that no but
is not running on ideas he's in fact ly
not an ideas man instead Biden is
running on electability the notion that
only he only Joe Biden can beat Donald
Trump will let Biden's new campaign ad
explain watch we know in our bones this
election is different the stakes are
higher the threat more serious
have to be Donald Trump and all the
polls agreed Joe Biden is the strongest
Democrat to do the job can restore the
soul of the nation battered by an
erratic vicious bullying president
strong steady stable leadership Biden
president got that strong steady stable
not doddering flaky weird no strong
steady stable that's Joe Biden
self-description
he's the most experienced candidate in
the race he often says in fact he's the
only vice president in American history
who served more than two full terms in
office and that's how he met the
survivors of the parklands shooting at
the White House just last year last year
when the rest of us assumed that Mike
Pence was the vice president but no
watch I watch what happened those kids
from Parkland came up to see me now as
vice president they went under the and
son some of you covered it there you go
pretty impressive you thought that pence
was the VP no Biden was still the vice
president and none of us knew it but it
turns out there are a lot of things you
didn't know about Joe Biden for example
by this conventional biography the one
you can find in Wikipedia claims he went
from a private high school to college
and then write to law school he
graduated 76th in a class of 85 students
that's the Biden we thought we knew what
we didn't know was that while becoming
an attorney Biden was also working deep
underground literally underground as a
coal miner streaked face and headlamp
included and that's why he scoffed
sometimes still all these years later
mining just takes it out of a man listen
to him explain hope you all hold against
me but I am a hard coal miner anthracite
coal Scranton Pennsylvania okay that's
where I was born and raised and it's
nice to be back in coal country yeah
it's a coal miner it's true you should
also know that Biden was also at various
times a fireman a hard-boiled homicide
detective a gold miner in the Yukon and
a wise old Indian chief who slayed many
a bear in his day not your average
politician for sure needless to say
Biden was also a war hero
he was not in his generations war
deferments kept Joe Biden out of Vietnam
no as the oldest American soldier / US
senator serving in Iraq braving
relentless enemy fire to bring democracy
to that bow knighted nation watch number
one you take all the truths out you
better have helicopters ready to take
those 3,000 civilians inside the green
zone where I've been seven times and
shot at yeah he's been shot at others we
should tell you remember that moment
differently they claim Biden was simply
staying at a hotel in Iraq when a mortar
exploded hundreds of yards away a mortar
that didn't even delay the breakfast
buffet but whatever did Joe Biden was
yet another death-defying moment in a
long life as the world's most
interesting senator listened at the time
he nearly got killed by the Taliban if
you want to know where Al Qaeda lives
you want to know where bin Laden is come
back to Afghanistan with me come back to
the error my helicopter was forced down
with a three-star general and three
United States senators at 10,500 feet in
the middle of those mountains I can tell
you where they are now once again we
must tell you there was some dispute
about what actually happened other
possibly more factually reliable
participants claimed that Biden's
helicopter landed because of a snow
storm not because of some bin Laden was
personally trying to murder Biden but
don't tell senator Biden that nor should
you tell him that nobody can remember
seeing him at all those civil rights
sit-ins and demonstrations he claims to
have led in the 1960s either
he and Martin Luther King leaders of the
movement that's his story he's got a
million stories like that and he's the
hero of every single one of them take a
seat and he'll tell you ladies and
gentlemen and remember as you listen
that this man this former coal miner and
civil rights leader is the single say
'no spur s'en running for president as a
democrat this year meditate on that for
a minute